All right, let's recap what happened.
You borrowed 100 shares from Joe, so
that's indicated by this
sort of empty box here.
You sold those 100 shares to Lisa.
So now you have $10,000 in your account,
but you still owe Joe those 100 shares.
Let's suppose that since that time,
IBM has dropped in price and
now it's selling at $90.
You can make a profit from that,
and you want to go ahead and exit.
So you approach Lisa and say, hey,
can I buy those 100 shares back?
And she says, no, I want to keep IBM.
Well, that's a little bit of a problem,
but fortunately, there's lots of people
who have shares of IBM and
would be willing to sell them to you.
So Lisa's now out of the picture and
not part of this transaction anymore.
But, there is somebody else out there,
Nate, who's got a hundred shares and
he's willing to sell them.
So you buy a hundred shares from
Nate and give them back to Joe.
So your obligation to Joe,
is now completed.
IBM was selling at $90 so
you had to give Joe $9000.
But remember you had $10000, so
the net result after everything is
said and done is you've got a $1000.
And you don't have any
obligation any longer to Joe.
So that's how short selling works.
Now I personalized this story by talking
about Joe and Lisa and Nate and so on.
In reality you don't have to make these
personal agreements with any of these
people, your broker
makes all that happen.
Your broker is sitting here in
between all those actors and
making all this happen for you.
Well this all sounds wonderful
doesn't it, what can go wrong?